[Music]
how have you been how's your life going
what's going on um well I had a baby Oh
congratulations
[Music]
my wife had had the baby yes to be fully
honest and you know there's this weird
time before the baby where she was
pregnant for like nine months and when
people tell you you're gonna have a baby
everyone's Bozell what changed my life
and made everything different the first
thing I thought or said was I don't care
if it's a boy or a girl I just want a
healthy baby that's what everyone says
yeah first thing I thought was I'll take
an unhealthy boy really I want my King
Joffrey
I married my sister better I want to
have a King Joffrey that's what you want
well I married my sister wait a minute
all right so you was so-so oh god you
can't say that you really can't say that
but you did so we're gonna work with it
you so you know there are ways of
finding out what you're gonna have right
yes and we I couldn't wait for that yet
to wait like three and a half months for
the ultrasound so I've friend of mine
said you could go to a drugstore CVS or
whatever and get a test that your wife
has to pee in fYI that was a big mistake
on my part and took it home to my wife
she peed in it and it said we're having
a boy and on the box it says it's a
50-50 thing but I took it hundred
percent it's a boy okay and I was okay I
was excited
yeah so as time went on we eventually
had to go to the doctor it's just like
you know I already got it figured out we
don't really need to go right we get to
the doctor and we walk into the room and
she sits in this like big leather
looking like your wife my wife's for the
ultrasound yes Suzanne Suzanne sit she
sits on this big leather Brookstone
looking chair they have like a little
what looks like they pulled out of an
elementary school classroom for me right
just a plastic metal death trap yeah and
I realized the appointments not about me
it's for her and the this young hotshot
doctor comes in and he takes this device
and he he puts it on her stomach you
know to get a picture I don't know if
it's Bluetooth technology I don't know
what it
but he puts it on her stomach and he
says all the babies too small still we
can't get it from there and then without
even saying anything he takes the same
device and puts it inside her vagina and
we're talking something roughly three
times the size of my penis and it's just
like she's not even supposed to know
that's possible right
you know I'm sure creates a whole new
yeah yeah really changes the scale of
everything yeah but hey insurance is
covering it so enjoy it while you can
yeah and after he does that we get I
look up and there's three big-screen TVs
like we're inside of an ESPN phone it's
airing the inside of my wife and and
first time I'd seen it that well and I'm
looking at it and he finds a great image
of the baby any freeze-frame sitting he
says hey if you guys want to know the
sex with a baby I can tell you and I
said oh we appreciate it but I already
got it figured out I bought a test at
CVS so I think we're good it's a boy by
the way and the doctor said okay well
I'm a doctor and it's definitely a girl
and oh and I'm a doctor in your CVS and
then he just moves on is if he didn't
just shatter my dreams and talking to my
wife and all I'm doing is staring at
these three big screen TVs looking the
hardest I've ever looked for a dick in
my life do I know if baby penises look
like just looking and looking and
finally I saw it like two minutes in a
real good looking I look and I see it
and I say hey doctor sorry to interrupt
all this whatever you're doing but isn't
that a penis and he did me a huge favor
of walking up to the screen in a very
mocking way looking very close at it and
then turning back to my wife and saying
if he thinks that's a penis then I want
to know who got you pregnant all of a
sudden I'm at my own Comedy Central Road
dr. Rickles has stepped in and so what
happened so well I'm just now I'm
curious like who ends up being who ends
up being right well we move on from that
and we go home and eventually we have
another doctor's appointment I'm holding
I know what it is we go into this the
new doctor different doctor this time
and this time you can do it over the
stomach so that's later sometimes gone
time has gone by he can do it over the
stomach on my wife's not being
penetrated I feel very comfortable yeah
and that's the main thing yeah yeah I
felt I could be me finally you know and
you might be the worst guy here thank
you thank you I've seen them all I've
met them all yeah so he gets a great
shot of the baby and he freezes it he
says hey if you guys want to know the
sex I can tell you my wife cut some
offices oh no we already know it's a
girl the last doctor told us and he
looked at me as if he knew what was
happening and said well what do you
think it is
and I said 100% confident it's a man
it's not a boy it's a man and then the
my wife gave me this look that could
have been interpreted as either please
stop talking or I'm so sorry I've got to
spend the rest of my life with you yeah
and then the voice of Jesus came out of
the doctor and he said he's right
it's a boy and then he freeze frames
that on some tablet device that he has
and like we're watching an instant
replay circles my son's penis draws an
arrow to it and then writes in huge
letters baby penis kid nah yeah I mean
you brought did you bring this
[Applause]
oh good lord
okay so whenever the good thing he put
the qualifier baby on there just so yeah
a goat penis or an elderly man Eldon